et avec nous Arnaud Benedetti bonjour
Arnaud merci d'être là rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
Frédéric David bonjour Frédéric merci
d'être avec nous directeur général
opinion de l'Ifop et Quentin est avant
nous a rejoint rebonjour Quentin on va
parler de l'affaire du fond Marianne le
Sénat a fini ses auditions il rédige son
rapport qui s'annonce accablant va voir
ça Quentin avec vous le font Marianne
qui a été créé après la mort de Samuel
Patty alors cette affaire a-t-elle abîmé
la lutte contre le séparatisme ce sera
le débat de ce club et autres questions
la laïcité est-elle en danger dans notre
pays oui pour une majorité d'entre vous
on verra votre sondage Frédéric on verra
pourquoi et comment la défendre mais
d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans nos
régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Avignon retrouver Anaïs Vaugon bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous Anaïs
vous êtes journaliste à Vaucluse Matin
et avec vous on va faire la connaissance
d'Enzo disons et de sa famille
oui bonjour on a recueilli le témoignage
poignant d'une famille qui vit dans le
Gard près d'Uzès avec ce petit Enzo qui
atteint d'un cas unique en France de
trisomie 13 alors c'est vrai qu'on
connaît beaucoup la trisomie 21 mais moi
la trisomie 13 j'en avais jamais entendu
parler c'est la plus rare des trisomie
viable une anomalie donc chromosomique
qui est caractérisée par des
malformations multiples il y a un
sixième doigt aux mains au pied des
reins plus gros que le normal et
d'autres malformations et c'est surtout
que cette trisomie 13 laisse peu
d'espoir de survie après son diagnostic
quand il est né Enzo on lui donnait
trois mois à vivre et puis là vous voyez
sur les images il va avoir bientôt 10
ans un petit garçon battant il a subi
beaucoup d'interventions et de passages
à l'hôpital il ne voit pas il ne parle
pas il ne marche pas par contre il adore
la musique voilà
il a même survécu à la covid qui n'a
attrapé
quand il était à l'IME mais donc ça lui
a déclenché quand même une épilepsie
partielle qui fait que ça l'empêche de
dormir il dort jamais c'est aussi la
rencontre dans ce
reportage de la rencontre de deux
parents qui se plaignent jamais qui sont
très actifs pour avoir leur association
et qui décide pour la première fois de
sortir du silence et de médiatiser du
coup cette enfin leur histoire
à travers à travers le récit on comprend
aussi le parcours du combattant de cette
famille
c'est ça c'est
une vie qu'on peut imaginer
il se battent au quotidien ça coûte très
cher et en fait il dénonce aussi ces
deux parents
l'absence de prise en charge il dénonce
voilà l'administration
cette prise en charge qui est pathotel
par exemple pour adapter le siège auto
parce que enzo est grandit et du coup il
a un fauteuil aussi roulant de plus en
plus lourd il doit faire des cagnottes
en ligne plutôt que d'avoir des aides de
l'État donc c'est vrai que c'est ça qui
est compliqué pour eux à comprendre
comment en fait cette maladie elle est
reportée répertoriée comme mortelle du
coup on leur dit ben on peut pas
s'occuper de vous
aussi une erreur médicale parce qu'en
fait Enzo
l'état d'Enzo n'a jamais été dépisté
pendant les échographies et ça pour les
parents c'est incompréhensible
merci Anaïs merci beaucoup pour ce récit
de du petit Enzo et du combat de sa
famille merci d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde la Une de Vaucluse Matin c'est
un autre sujet elle a une de Vaucluse
Matin c'est le directeur du festival
d'Avignon on le Festival d'Avignon qui
va débuter dans une dizaine de jours ce
sera le 5 juillet Tiago Rodriguez sur la
scène de l'info c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Anaïs d'avoir été
avec nous on va passer au débat de ce
club on va parler laïcité séparative on
va commencer en parlant du fond Marianne
Quentin parce que le fond Marianne on
parle beaucoup de l'affaire et de
Marlène Schiappa mais le fond Marianne
il a été créé après la mort de Samuel
Paty pour lutter contre le séparatisme
les sénateurs qui enquêtent sur son
attribution sur la sa finalité ils ont
fini leurs auditions le rapport
s'annonce s'acca blanc en matière de
lutte contre la radicalisation en ligne
un rapport qui est en cours d'écriture
les sénateurs qui sont en ce moment en
train de rédiger ce rapport qui sera
rendu au début du mois de juillet et
effectivement c'est la question qui se
pose et c'était le combat en faveur de
la laïcité qui était le grand perdant de
la faire du fond Marianne le fond Maria
on nous rappelle ce sont 2,5 millions
d'euros à louer à 17 associations il
avait été lancé en grande pompe on peut
le dire par Malène Schiappa au printemps
2020 or on réalise qu'il aura fallu deux
ans et deux enquêtes journalistiques de
nos confrères du journal Marianne et de
France 2 pour qu'on se pose la question
du bilan de ce fond Marianne et Quentin
c'est l'un des grands reproches adressés
à Marlène Schiappa elle n'a pas suivi
l'évolution du projet voilà la première
intéressée elle-même n'évoque pas le
suivi du fond Marianne quand elle est
interrogée en commission d'enquête par
les sénateurs écoutez un extrait de son
propos d'introduction lors de son
audition sous serment devant la
commission d'enquête c'était donc
mercredi dernier écoutez vous avez le
ministre qui
des politiques publiques qui
représentent également ces politiques
publiques qui en est comptable devant
bien sûr le Parlement mais aussi devant
les citoyens soit de manière directe
soit de manière indirecte par
l'intermédiaire des médias c'est le rôle
du ministre le rôle de l'administration
c'est la mise en œuvre de ces politiques
publiques impulsées par le ministre la
mise en œuvre et le suivi et le ministre
en cela s'appuie sur la conscience qu'il
a dans les collaborateurs ce qu'il a
choisi ou ce qu'il a trouvé en arrivant
qui renvoie vers l'administration pour
ce qui est du suivi comme si une fois
l'annonce passée elle n'avait pas la
mission de s'assurer de l'efficacité de
sa politique et quand on voit le maigre
bilan de l'association de Mohamed
cifaoui la principale bénéficiaire du
fond Marianne avec
355000 euros on parle de 1763 abonnés
sur les réseaux sociaux 500 publication
sur Tik Tok Instagram et Twitter avec
des vidéos en plus qui sont très peu
consultés regardez les compteurs de la
page Youtube de ilaik ou i like le
projet de ma médecin oui ce sont
quelques centaines de vues à chaque fois
et cette absence de portage politique
c'est l'un des reproches qui est déjà
adressé par les sénateurs le président
de la commission d'enquête socialiste
Claude Raynal à notre micro j'ai dit
dernier
je pointerai plus généralement la
question de la responsabilité de l'État
quand on lance ce type de de projet
au-delà de la personne même de Madame
Schiappa ça donne l'impression que
l'État réagit à un événement qui
l'affirme des politiques et puis que
très rapidement tout ça est oublié ou en
tout cas et laisser après derrière dans
des formules qui ne sont que des
formules de gestion et sur laquelle il
n'y a plus de portage politique et ça
sur un sujet de cette nature ces
catastrophique à la même chose pour le
rapporteur LR Jean-François Husson de
cette commission d'enquête
l'édifonctionnements du fond Marianne
sont d'autant plus navrant qu'ils se
font dans le contexte rien vous le
disait tout à l'heure d'une réponse à
l'attentat à l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
écouter
sa mémoire à Samuel Paty ne mérite pas
d'être sali je pense qu'on a une
exigence et un devoir d'éthique au
regard de ces événements et de ses
valeurs à laquelle on dit être attaché
évidemment
liberté a été fraternité mais aussi
effectivement laïcité et le combat
contre le séparatisme il ne faut pas
transiger avec cette exigence et je
crois malheureusement les dernières
auditions nous ont montré qu'il y avait
finalement ce lien cette exigence on en
est me semble-t-il très éloigné voilà et
on l'entend les sénateurs et qui pointe
là une défaillance d'État Oriane au-delà
même du kamalen Schiappa mais dernière
information problématique au remaniement
de juillet 2022 lorsque Sonia bac S
succède à Marlène Schiappa elle ne
reçoit aucune information sur le fond
Marianne le dossier ministre qui est
bien donné au successeur et dont elle
hérite sur les détails des politiques
publiques de son ministère il ne
contient au cune note à ce moment-là sur
le fond Marianne merci Quentin Arnaud
est-ce que cette affaire du fond
Marianne abîme la lutte contre les
séparatisme et saline la mémoire
je ne sais pas si ça
contraint ou si ça abîme la lutte contre
le séparatisme islamiste ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça renvoie une image du
fonctionnement de l'État qui est pour le
moins catastrophique en l'occurrence
qu'une mini ministre Vienne devant une
commission d'enquête du Sénat dont il
faut saluer le travail parce que c'était
des commissions d'enquête qui sont
pluralistes et qui font un travail de
fond
viennent et décharge sa responsabilité
sur ses collaborateurs sont dit long
aujourd'hui sur le niveau de
responsabilité politique donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet et un vrai problème moi je
crois que dans tout autre démocratie qui
fonctionne normalement madame Schiappa
ne serait plus au gouvernement les
rentrer en Scandinavie on serait au
Royaume-Uni on serait même dans des pays
latins en Espagne en Italie je pense que
Madame siapas ne siègerait plus au
gouvernement le vrai problème que ça
pose c'est aujourd'hui de savoir pour
quelle raison finalement on a un
affaissement éthique dans le
fonctionnement de l'État et ça c'est une
question essentielle alors après si vous
voulez l'autre sujet que ça pose c'est
que on ne répond pas de la commune avec
de la communication politique à un sujet
aussi fondamental que celui de du danger
islamiste qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
fait on voit bien que face à un
événement qui est un événement tragique
qui a sidéré la nation est à sidéré
l'opinion publique la première réaction
de de la secrétaire d'État ou de la
ministre à l'époque a été finalement
d'essayer de nous offrir un produit de
communication qui était un produit de
communication qui lui permettait de
montrer que elle avait pris conscience
de la dangerosité que faisait peser sur
la société française
l'islam l'islam radical mais face à un
problème qui est un problème presque
d'ordre de civilisation on sait très
bien que c'est pas le fond Marianne qui
va permettre d'absorber cette difficulté
oui je passe complètement ce Carnot
vient de dire c'est vrai que dans les
enquêtes qualitatives où chaque semaine
demande qu'est-ce qui a marqué dans
l'actualité sincèrement Oriane l'affaire
du fond Marianne a été faiblement
mémorisée faiblement restitué c'est pas
extrêmement simple ça n'empêche pas que
il y a ce traumatisme lié à la faire
Samuel Paty moi je suis frappé de voir
que bien sûr une affaire chasse l'autre
les médias on parle chaque année le 16
octobre et on vous en avez parlé ce qui
est très bien mais c'est un trauma
permanent chez les français chez les
enseignants surtout j'étais la semaine
dernière au
congrès du CNAL le Comité national
d'action laïque à Montpellier avec le
maire Michael de la fosse où on voit des
enseignants qui en parlent encore qui
voit ça comme une sorte de rupture
anthropologique et quelque chose qui est
un impensé ça vous le mesurez encore
chez enseignants mais j'ai l'ensemble
des Français c'est un événement hors
norme maintenant je vais pas répéter ce
qu'a dit Arnaud ce que vous avez dit on
voit des dysfonctionnements qui ne
peuvent qu'agacer qui ne sont en
décalage avec ce qu'attendent les
Français du politique qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent du politique 2 l'incarnation
et pas seulement mettre un fond Marianne
sur une personne qui va le mener il ne
ils sont très gênés face à la dilution
des responsabilités c'est pas moi c'est
l'administration c'est pas moi c'est mon
cabinet et puis c'est vrai que face à la
question de la laïcité qui est vraiment
un enjeu très fort pour les Français
dans une enquête hifiduciale pour SUD
RADIO il y a 15 jours on avait deux
tiers des Français des majoritaires
partout qui considéraient que la laïcité
était en danger clairement on n'est pas
niveau des attentes sans préjugés de
ceux qui sortira du rapport du audiences
on a vu un Mohammed 6 fois oui
extrêmement offensif et pas du tout dans
une dans une logique d'acceptation de
de culpabilité mais c'était son c'était
son droit mais en tout cas c'est vrai
que c'est une affaire elle dans ta
chambre rien la prise de conscience des
Français sur le danger islamiste sur le
danger séparatiste sur le danger
obscurantiste il y avait eu un colloque
en février là-dessus dans le cadre des
Rencontres Claude Erignac mais
effectivement pour les Français qui ont
eu affaire qui ont qui connaissent cette
affaire franchement ça ne passe pas je
partage que dit Frédéric je ne suis pas
du tout sûr et même je crois pas du tout
que ça entache une quelconque manière la
prise de conscience des Français face à
ce danger le problème est ailleurs alors
que par contre ceux qui luttent
aujourd'hui contre la République se
servent de cette affaire en effet pour
essayer de décrédibiliser le combat
légitime contre les formes de de de de
d'islamisme les plus les plus radicales
ça ça me paraît une évidence mais dans
le fond quand même l'opinion publique on
en parlera peut-être tout tout à l'heure
me semble plutôt tenir
de la persistance du traumatisme de
l'assassinat de Samuel
patyna puisque on a compris le fond
Marianne les sénateurs vont rendre leur
rapport début juillet mais une nouvelle
commission d'enquête a déjà été annoncée
pour la reprise parlementaire au mois
d'octobre sur l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty élément dans et bien la politique
publique autour de l'enseignant est-ce
qu'il y a eu des défaillances dans sa
protection etc c'est la sœur de de du
professeur d'histoire-géographie qui a
écrit au président du Sénat et au
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat pour leur demander de s'emparer de
ce sujet et danser cette commission
d'enquête et le Sénat a accepté et donc
ce sera la prochaine étape avec deux
commissions qui seront à la manœuvre la
commission des lois et la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation et qui
seront à la manœuvre en octobre pour
cette commission d'enquête qui s'annonce
pas de vagues qui règnerait au sein de
de l'éducation nationale il faut
rappeler que ce fond mar intervient bien
évidemment après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty mais il faut aussi se souvenir que
les conditions les derniers jours de
Samuel Patier ont été des jours où il y
a des questions qui se posent sur la
façon dont il a pu être protégé par son
administration et cette affaire n'a pas
été c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
pour l'instant purger il y a quand même
des interrogations tout à fait légitimes
qui soient je rappelle quand même qu'il
avait été convoqué il avait été convoqué
par sa hiérarchie qu'on s'est expliqué
sur le contenu pédagogique de son cours
donc ce qui montre bien que lui-même
était dans une situation où il était
quasiment peut-être pas mis en cause
mais en tout cas interrogé par sa
hiérarchie donc ça aussi en effet c'est
une question qu'il faut ce qu'il faut se
poser oui et de l'enquête Ifop restitué
de la semaine dernière pour le covid et
national d'action laïque auprès de 650
enseignants tout degrés soit une
prioritaire ou pas nous avons 42% des
enseignants qui déclarent que l'affaire
Samuel Paty a eu un impact sur leur
manière d'enseigner et un sur deux parmi
ces 42 parmi ces 42 100% qui considère
que il se sont parfois auto censurés ils
ont limité leurs paroles dans un
contexte de contestation en explosion de
la loi de 2004 57% des enseignants ont
constaté des contestations c'est 18
points de plus par rapport à une autre
enquête faite en 2018 donc avant le
drame Samuel Passy et 53% qui
personnellement ont vu leur enseignement
contesté on est sur un mouvement massif
de contestation et dans ce cadre là oui
on ne se sent pas assez soutenu le
padvac c'est absolument dévastateur et
l'école comme sanctuaire a peut-être
vécu puisque dans cette même enquête un
enseignant sur cinq 18% à le sentiment
qu'il y a des pressions extérieures
presque quotidiennes autour des lycées
pour ne pour remettre en cause le
principe laïque il y a une faiblesse
politique au sein de l'éducation
nationale mais au-delà dans la lutte
contre le séparatisme dans la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical
ça fait plusieurs décennies que il y a
une faiblesse souvenez-vous de l'affaire
tu vois le Creil qui est j'allais dire
un moment fondateur de ce de cette de
ces de ces tensions ou déjà on l'avait
vu un pouvoir politique qui d'une
certaine manière c'est à dire j'ose pas
à l'époque qui était ministre de
l'éducation nationale avait plutôt
décharger sur le Conseil d'État la
responsabilité de de finalement de fixer
un certain nombre de principes
nous rappeler le voile de Creil ce sont
deux jeunes filles qui dans un collège
ou dans un lycée à Creil arrivé voilé
dans le dans le dans l'enceinte de
l'école et le proviseur de l'époque
c'était celle établissement c'était
opposé à ce que ces deux jeunes filles
puissent entrer voilées à l'école ce qui
avait créé une polémique nationale donc
on est si vous voulez dans un dans une
tendance qui est longue qui est lourde
et où on voit quand même que l'État n'a
pas été en mesure pour des tas de
raisons ce serait beaucoup trop long de
les expliquer de finalement de fixer une
doctrine qui fixe d'une certaine manière
une frontière entre ce que nous devons
faire et ce que nous ne devons pas faire
et on retrouve exactement cette ce
problème d'absence de direction de
normes de dilution des responsabilités
quand dans une enquête publiée ce jour
pour SUD RADIO face à la question non
pas du voile mais des camises pour
certains jeunes garçons des abeilles a
pour des jeunes filles on demande aux
Français mais qui doit donner le la on a
78% qui considèrent que le caractère
religieux de ses vêtements doit être
défini automatiquement et nationalement
par l'Éducation nationale par l'État 22%
seulement et là c'est la doctrine
officielle qui est non ça c'est une
autre question on va t'en parler ce doit
être les chefs d'établissement au cas
par cas et les chefs d'établissement se
sentent parfois abandonnés sans règles
précises et do vous voyez avec des cas
différents selon les trajectoires selon
les personnalités alors que les Français
soit une règle commune ce qui est quand
même le fondement d'une réplique c'est
donner des règles avec dans ce dans ce
cadre-là oui un vous le voyez un rejet
très fort une un souhait que la session
scolaire l'autorise pas les élèves des
collègues et public apporter des
vêtements traditionnels comme les abeyas
ou des camis non mais tout se passe
comme si vous voulez on reproduisait les
mêmes terres diversations on parlait de
l'affaire de Creil l'affaire de Creil il
en est Jospin ministre de l'éducation
nationale avait finalement demandé
déléguer au Conseil d'État le soin de
fixer un certain nombre de règles dans
la matière et de la même manière quand
on écoute le ministre de l'éducation
nationale lui aussi décharge sa
responsabilité sur les chefs
d'établissement c'est quand même un
moment donné il faut le rappeler quand
vous êtes ministre ou politique de
décider de fixer les règles
effectivement et régulièrement papa
Ndiaye est interrogé sur ce sujet
notamment lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement ou les sénateurs peuvent
voilà poser des questions à l'exécutif
et très régulièrement il dit qu'il ne
faut pas faire de
consigne nationale parce que ce serait
rentré dans le jeu de quelle couleur de
vêtements quel nombre de centimètres de
tissu pour lui c'est c'est
voilà elle est trop loin et en plus
ouvrir la possibilité d'être contesté
devant les tribunaux administratifs par
les personnes qui refuseraient cette
consigne nationale et donc c'est vrai
qu'il renvoie systématiquement au chef
d'établissement qui sont un peu laissés
en race campagne pour devoir comme cela
jauger si c'est un vêtement qui est
porté dans le cadre d'une voilà volonté
traditionnelle ou confessionnelle et
c'est vrai que c'est un dilemme
compliqué à trancher pour l'échelle
d'établissement au-delà de l'éducation
on a posé la question à George Sérignac
quel grand maître du Grand Orient de
France qui était là il y a quelques
instants sur la menace que représente
l'islam sur la République on va écouter
sa réponse
dans notre modèle aujourd'hui
républicain
bien sûr que cette ce modèle est menacé
tous les jours ce qui apparaît en
premier lieu c'est c'est l'islam
politique qui régulièrement fait une
offensive depuis
une trentaine d'années on va dire c'est
apparu en 89 avec le l'affaire du voile
de Creil on voit bien et qui gagne de
plus en plus du terrain pour ça je ne
sais pas si le gagne de plus en plus de
terrain il faudrait vous savez c'est
très difficile à apprécier parce qu'il y
a l'effet de loupe il y a les médias il
y a l'instrumentalité de part et d'autre
Arnaud est-ce qu'on est dans un effet de
loupe où est-ce qu'il y a une menace de
l'islam politique aujourd'hui sur la
laïcité sur la République
elle s'exprime de manière j'allais dire
récurrente par des gestes de défis qui
sont lancés très souvent par des jeunes
et des jeunes filles en l'occurrence qui
alors foi pour affirmer leur identité il
y a peut-être aussi une dimension de
révolte adolescente qui peut être je
veux dire intégré mais enfin globalement
on sait très bien que derrière cela il y
a une mise en cause à la fois de
l'autorité de l'État il y a une mise en
cause du principe de la laïcité et il y
a donc des principes qui sont fondateurs
de la République et puis il y a une mise
en cause aussi de la conception et du
rôle que l'on se fait de la femme dans
la société si vous voulez quand même ces
vêtements sont des vêtements qui mal qui
qui exprime qui exprime d'une certaine
manière l'acceptation de la soumission
quand vous discutez avec des féministes
qui ont combattu dans les années 60-70
pour l'émancipation des femmes les
féministes historiques les fondatrices
du combat féministe elles sont très
explicites et très claires sur j'allais
dire la perception de ce de ce phénomène
oui il y a un vrai danger oui il y a un
vrai danger je parle complètement ce
qu'il y a été dit avec une
invisibilisation des corps et ce qui est
très notable ce qui me frappe j'ai
travaillé sur ces sujets c'est la
fracture générationnelle on a montré ce
son pas fait du ciel pour SUD RADIO qui
est restitué ce matin alors on voit
seulement 23% de l'ensemble des Français
considèrent que il faut autoriser ses
vêtements dans les écoles ces
minoritaires dans toutes les catégories
alors ça monte à 40 % chez sympathisants
la France insoumise on se souvient de la
prise opposition sur BFM dimanche
dernier toujours que Mélenchon en
rupture totale avec ce qu'il disait par
le passé 40% chez élevé mais ce qui est
très intéressant Oriane c'est que ce 23%
devient majoritaire chez le moins de 25
ans sur la question laïque il y a une
fracture entre les plus jeunes et le
reste de la société dans une enquête
Fati il y a 15 jours on demande
qu'est-ce que c'est que la laïcité
aujourd'hui les jeunes répondent
majoritairement c'est assuré la liberté
de conscience et assurer l'égalité et la
visibilité entre les religions c'est le
c'est le syndrome McDo hein venez comme
vous êtes alors que les plus de 35 ans
et vraiment on a des écarts très très
forts oui c'est
mettre c'est faire reculer l'influence
des religions dans notre société et
séparer les religions et la politique on
a sur le même mot et c'est un problème
comment comprendre comment débattre
quand derrière un même mot on met un mot
quand même chargé d'une vraie
symbole de notre République on met des
exceptions des sens des contenus
différents c'est ce qui va générationnel
qui est le plus inquiétant je pense
c'est aussi une crise de la transmission
ça veut dire que d'une certaine manière
les principes qui sont les principes
fondateurs de la nation et de la
République n'ont plus été
vraisemblablement
transmis aux jeunes et puis il y a un
autre sujet si vous voulez qu'est-ce qui
apparaît les jeunes ont une vision qui
est une vision qui se rapproche du
modèle américain le modèle américain est
très différent d'une autre en termes de
relation religieux tout simplement pour
des raisons historiques la France
finalement a fondé la laïcité parce que
elle a vécu des guerres de religion donc
la considéré qu'il fallait qu'il y ait
un espace public qui soit un espace
public
puisse vivre ensemble avec une liberté
de conscience certes mais sans que le
religieux intervienne dans disons le
débat politique en tout cas directement
les États-Unis se sont construits les
États-Unis se sont construits
différemment totalement différemment
c'est à dire que pour les États-Unis ce
sont des gens qui ont fui l'Europe parce
qu'ils étaient persécutés religieusement
et il fallait maintenir la liberté
religieuse donc on a si vous voulez des
histoires qui sont totalement
différentes sauf que l'histoire
française c'est pas l'histoire
américaine et c'est totalement et je
crois que c'est un point absolument
essentiel pour bien comprendre le dire
ce qui se joue aujourd'hui à l'intérieur
de notre société et notamment avec les
jeunes un dernier mot Frédéric peut être
sur la loi de 1905
fondatrice sur de la laïcité vous avez
posé la question aux Français est-ce
qu'il faut garder tel quel la loi de
1905 la réponse est assez clairement
j'ai pu le chiffre en tête mais
clairement les Français sont sur une
logique de maintien en l'état de cette
loi de 1905 je me souviens d'un autre
sondage fait après l'assassinat de
Samuel patio une majorité de Français
n'auraient pas été que dans le triptyque
républicain on rajoute un quatrième
volet si je puis dire la laïcité et
c'est vrai que supprimer cette loi alors
peut-être que c'est au modèle américain
dont parle Arnaud ça ne compte ça ne
concerne qu'une minorité de français 8%,
certains souhaitent assouplir notamment
des sympathisants de la gauche de la
gauche France insoumise Europe Écologie
Les Verts mais les Français voient cette
fois comme un véritable rempart d'où ce
désarroi des enseignants à l'école et se
désarroi des parents face aux atteintes
multiples et le sentiment que le pouvoir
politique n'a pas pris la mesure des
dangers que courent laïcité à l'école
merci pour ce débat on va vendredi vous
le savez de weekend on vous propose une
balade à travers nos régions marions
Villeret nous emmène suivre la ligne
verte du Voyage à Nantes un parcours
culturel urbain installer depuis 2012 il
revient chaque année avec de nouvelles
œuvres d'art et pour cette saison c'est
la sculpture qui est à l'honneur
à Nantes pour découvrir la ville il
suffit de suivre la ligne verte un
parcours urbain de 22 km qui permet au
touristes comme au nantais d'allier
visite de la ville et découverte
d'oeuvres d'art en accès libre comme ces
terres de jeux de l'architecte japonais
qu'il n'y a Maruyama une installation
issue du Voyage à Nantes un événement
culturel lancé en 2012 par Jean Blaise
et qui a complètement remodelé l'espace
urbain le point de départ c'était
montrer la ville d'abord à travers le
regard des artistes comment une ville
qui a eu de gros problèmes qui a eu des
bombardements qui avaient les
comblements de la Loire
la fin des chantiers navals qui étaient
quand même son identité la création
industrielle
comment cette ville peut s'identifier à
nouveau à une ville énergie créative
c'était ça l'idée au fur et à mesure des
éditions Lara donc envahi la ville
certaines œuvres du Voyage à Nantes sont
devenus pérennes comme les loges du pas
de côté de Philippe Ramette
le maître à ruban de liane bourgeois
ou encore la jungle intérieure dévore
la sculptrice Marion vers boom fait
partie des artistes retenus pour
l'édition 2023 avec son équipe elle
entame l'installation de plusieurs de
ses colonnes dans le passage
Sainte-Croix je trouve ça important de
pouvoir s'insérer dans dans la
géographie de cette ville
l'aspect gratuit me
passionne parce qu'elle évoque aussi
quelque chose une circulation libre des
corps et de leur rencontre avec les
oeuvres et c'est ça que je suis aussi
depuis
le début du Voyage à Nantes cette année
l'accent est mis sur la statuaire de
nouvelles figure vont donc apparaître
dans l'espace public comme ces statues
dansantes de l'artiste chinois judgen
mais d'autres vont descendre de leur
piédestal c'est le cas du général
d'Empire pierre Cambronne dont la
réplique qui est en cours de
finalisation si retraint en verre de
muscadet en terrasse c'était l'idée à
travers cette façon humoristique de
détourner les pauses de ces statuts
c'était de les rapprocher des visiteurs
les visiteurs puissent aller au plus
près de ces statuts les toucher et
puissent jouer à avec et c'était surtout
de les mettre de mettre en lumière tout
toutes les statues qu'on peut avoir dans
nos espaces publics c'est statues qui
nous regardent au quotidien devant
lesquels on passe sans trop sans trop
faire attention en tout 4 statuts seront
réinterprétées le général melinet sera à
couper à la rue des Deux Ponts à Nantes
l'art l'imaginaire ont envahi les rues
les clins d'oeil sont partout et le
voyage imprègne tout le territoire de la
Loire-Atlantique grâce à un dialogue
constant avec les élus et les habitants
on parle maintenant du voyage permanent
c'est à dire qu'on doit pouvoir venir
ici en février et avoir et faire une
balade et extraordinaire la création
artistique elle est pas seulement elle
se montre pas elle s'expose pas elle
pénètre à l'intérieur de la ville et
c'est ça la force je pense du Voyage à
Nantes ici
en 11 ans d'existence cette
manifestation a permis de booster la
destination 700 000 touristes ont été
enregistrés sur la saison estivale 2019
quant à l'édition 2023 du Voyage à
Nantes le top départ ce sera le premier
juillet
et voilà pour cette balade à Nantes la
semaine prochaine on ira en Corse sur
les remparts de Bonifacio
en attendant on va regarder ce qu'il y a
à la Une de mon quotidien régionaux avec
Quentin
[Musique]
bonsoir Ce petit sur mercible Rechercher
depuis dimanche autour de l'épave du
titanie voilà et ce sont les garde de
côté américain qui l'ont annoncé hier
soir et vous lisez ce matin à la une du
télégram le journal breton le petit
sous-marin a implosé les secours sur
place n'auraient rien pu faire dit le
titre effectivement dans les pages
intérieur on lit les dernières
informations sur cet accident des débris
du sous-marin ont été retrouvés par les
robots de recherche ils étaient près du
Titanic c'est débris par 4000 mètres de
fond à l'origine de l'accident il y
aurait une perte catastrophique de
pression il faudra maintenant
s'interroger sur les négligences
potentielles qui ont causé la mort des
cinq passages on continue Quentin avec
le progrès à Lyon qui quitte sur les
prix de l'alimentaire qui explosent
à aucun français quand il fait ses
courses c'est cher le progrès a fait
l'analyse des paniers des consommateurs
et parle de la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes avec une hausse de plus 25%
en un an et de s'interroger jusqu'où
monteront les prix avec un exemple le
prix du litre de lait qui prend 10% sur
le seul mois de juin les titres du
groupe Centre France reviennent sur les
phénomènes orageux qui ont touché ces
régions dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
on a eu très peur effectivement dans le
Berry dans le centre de la France il y
avait du vent de la grêle lundi dans le
Cher puis 48 heures plus tard un fort
phénomène orageux il est tombé en moins
de 24 heures l'équivalent d'un mois de
pluie le populaire du centre à Limoges
par le même d'un orage meurtrier Oriane
puisqu'une habitante de Corrèze n'a pas
survécu à l'incendie de sa maison frappé
par la foudre
voilà elle le vendredi avec un petit
sourire mais effectivement j'ai un petit
test musical pour vous Frédéric et
Arnaud alors même si on dispose
pas de buzzer en plateau mais je vous
propose une chanson vous devez
reconnaître soit le groupe ou le titre
allons-y bah écoutez effectivement cette
chanson
[Musique]
enjoy et enjoy the silence de Depeche
Mode bravo et effectivement voilà
mais effectivement vous voyez la Voix du
Nord qui raconte ce concert une
prestation que les fans vont garder
longtemps en mémoire parce
qu'apparemment le concert était
extraordinaire et certains fans et bien
s'instaient c'était la troisième fois
qui venait voir le groupe
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
merci beaucoup Frédéric et bravo
merci Arnaud on regarde la une de la
revue politique et parlementaire sexe
corps et politique des liaisons
tumultueuses c'est à la une de la revue
merci beaucoup merci Quentin à la
semaine prochaine pour un prochain quiz
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis si
vous voulez voir ou revoir cette
émission c'est sur public sénat.fr on se
retrouve lundi on vous souhaite un très
bon weekend
[Musique]